il faut redonner confiance à l'hôpital
il faut sortir de l'urgence dans
laquelle il est
[Musique]
après trois mois de travail une centaine
de personnes entendues trois
déplacements sur le terrain ce que l'on
observé sans effet l'hôpital est en
souffrance les personnels sont en
difficulté il y à une perte
d'attractivité
il ya beaucoup de lits fermés pour cause
de manque de personnel on l'a ressenti
cette perte de sens et surtout on a
ressenti à tous les échelons bien
évidemment au niveau des médecins mais
aussi au niveau des infirmiers au niveau
des aides soignants au niveau des
ambulanciers par exemple mais aussi au
niveau des directions qui dansaient ces
difficultés qui sont celles de l'hôpital
ne retrouvent plus leurs valeurs
premières que ces femmes veulent
apporter le meilleur dossier aux
patients donc il ya une tension sur des
effectifs indéniablement qui fait quand
on fait des personnels ont l'impression
de ne pas passer à 70 ans auprès auprès
d'eux à tous toujours mourir de ne pas
avoir de transmission les étudiants les
élèves infirmiers ce sont deux mâles mal
accueilli les médecins aussi sent sous
français et même indice relatif ou s'ils
revenaient les difficultés en a vu une
augmentation considérable des passages
aux urgences mais et pourtant la ville
fait aussi deux permanents soit et
assure des soins non programmés
il faut pouvoir jouer aussi sur
l'hôpital en amont en effet comment en
lien avec la ville avec des maisons
médicales de garde avec le renforcement
des hôpitaux de proximité
on peut diminuer cette pression sur le
pétard
les acteurs du terrain n'en veulent plus
des nouvelles lois il faut en revanche
redonner la place aux médecins mais
aussi au personnel soignant infirmier
demandant des décisions ça c'est majeur
il faut donner de la liberté aussi la
flexibilité et de l'autonomie vaut
revoir un financement indéniablement il
faut retravailler l'objectif national
des dépenses d'assurance maladie lors du
projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour que l'ondam ce qu'on
appelle madame hospitalier soit adaptée
aux besoins ça passe en effet par des
revalorisations ça surement un
renforcement des équipements aussi
déchargé des tâches administratives
chronophage pour pour les hospitaliers
quel que soit le niveau qui leur permet
justement de de dégager du temps
modifiable de plus haut rang seulement
9,7 certes sera un courbe vers une étude
australienne et mon truc en augmentant
le ratio des soignants auprès du patient
vous avez eu des gains forum du récit
joue en moins de réhospitalisation en
mortalité donc il ya un retour qui se
fait et ce qui peut coûter un moment et
on le retrouve très vite par la suite
[Musique]